Joining us now, one of the
two state
representatives who was expelled
last night, and that is Justin Jones.
Justin, good morning to you.
I really appreciate you joining us.
I know you haven't had any sleep
and I have to commend you right off
in the way
that you have conducted yourself,
you and your colleagues.
It has been notable.
And so thank you for joining us.
This has captured the attention
of the country.
Your message to the nation,
this is almost after
having been expelled.
How are you feeling
Sir, thank you so much
for having me this morning.
So I'll pray with very little sleep.
No need to apologize at all.
What what happened yesterday was
was a very sad day for democracy,
not just in Tennessee, but
in this nation. And so
I think that there's a lot of
thoughts going through my head.
The House Republicans chairman,
who you just saw in
this video, is still doubling down,
even though he is
the same Republican chairman
who engaged in inappropriate behavior
and is still in leadership,
as you can see, and was not expelled.
But, you know,
we have been expelled
for standing with our constituents.
But I have no regrets.
I will continue to speak up
for District 52 and for Tennesseans
who are demanding change
Let's let's talk
a little bit more about your colleague.
You're talking about Jeremy Faison.
He's a Republican caucus chair
in the state House.
Last night, he did an interview
with my colleague, Kaitlan Collins,
and he said he's wondering
why you have an apologize.
Let's listen
and then we'll get your response.
I'd like to add
to your
say they've not backed down
from that either.
I told them earlier that I feel like
if they would have said, you know what,
we messed up.
I mean, what American wouldn't
human bring forgiveness and redemption?
But they doubled down and went so far
as to stand in the world today
and said, I would do it again.
You haven't apologized.
What what is your response to that?
I mean, I think Representative Faison
needs to reflect on his own actions
as a representative
just earlier this year.
Last year,
I was in a phase
and pulled down the pants of a referee
because he got mad at a basketball game.
And he's still the Republican leadership,
not expelled, not sanctioned in any way.
And so for him to tell us to apologize
for standing up for our constituents,
I told the speaker,
I told that body yesterday
that I would apologize
when they apologized to the families
in covenant
and in the mass shootings
across this nation
politically,
but particularly in our state at Covenant
and in the wall of house
mass shooting for these reckless gun laws
that they pass that allowed people
to lose their loved ones,
apologize to the families
of the victims of these mass shootings.
And we will apologize for our
for our actions.
I think I know the answer to this,
but I have to ask you anyway,
just for the record,
so you could be reelected.
Do you want to serve again, just in
I mean, definitely.
I think what happened
was a travesty of democracy because it
they expelled the two youngest
black lawmakers,
which is no coincidence
from the Tennessee legislature.
Because we are outspoken,
because we fight for our district.
I will want to continue to do that.
And whether I'm inside the chamber,
outside the chamber,
because what we saw in Tennessee
yesterday was was an attack on democracy
and a very overt racism,
as you can see, that
the two youngest
black lawmakers were kicked out
but are calling my dear
sister Gloria Johnson, a white
woman, was not
and we see clearly
the nation is seeing clearly
what is going on in Tennessee.
Yeah.
Listen to say there's a double standard.
Some people may
sort of speculate about it,
but I think it is obvious,
considering that the two black members
who were men.
Right.
Were were expelled,
but the white woman was not.
What do you want to say to that?
Speak more, please.
I want to say that
this is what we've been challenging
all session was a very toxic
racist work environment
where we are not even allowed to speak.
That's why we went to the well,
because the speaker when it calling us,
he cut off our microphones.
He he ruled us how to order in time.
We brought up the issue of gun violence.
And when I went outside
to support the protesters,
he turned off my voting machine
so I couldn't even cast a vote
on the House floor.
I mean, this is what we've dealt
with all session.
And yesterday,
the nation was able to see that
we don't have democracy in Tennessee,
particularly when it comes
to black and brown communities.
And so
what we saw
yesterday was an attack on the future
of a multiracial democracy.
But we are in a state
where the birthplace of the Klan,
we were a state where we had a KKK statue
in our capital until very recently.
And we protested to have that removed.
But what they're trying to do
is to bring this back today
that we don't want to go to.
If I didn't know
this happened to me,
I would think that this was 1963
instead of 2023.
If the Nashville City
Council next week
wants to appoint you as an interim
representative to district,
you would do it
Most definitely, yes.
Let's talk about the issue.
Let me ask you why.
Why, considering all everything
that has happened right now,
why even go through all the rigmarole
because it's important
to let them know that democracy,
we will fight for democracy,
we'll fight for a multiracial democracy.
And so this
this extreme tactic to expel us
and to try to humiliate us
has only put a spotlight
of the world on Tennessee.
And so I will go back
because fighting for the future.
I'm 27 years old, fighting for the future
that I want to live
in, that I want my children to live in.
It's worth whatever sacrifice
that we have to give,
whether it's being expelled,
whether it is being
in a hostile environment.
Because I want to create a community
that our young people
can not just survive,
but they can thrive and flourish.
And that's what we were asking
them was a very basic
thing, was to ban assault weapons
so we can stop these mass shootings.
Instead, they responded
by assaulting democracy.
And that is shameful and it's very scary.
Do you think you can work with them?
There's so much opposition there.
I mean, we are the voice of the
opposition party.
Our role
in our party, there was only 24 members.
There's 20 to 75 Republicans.
Our role was to be a speed bump
to try and stop them
from driving this train off of the cliff
so that we no longer have democracy.
I mean, our job
was to be a voice of moral dissent.
Our job was to be a voice
of check on power.
That was what we did
and that's what we did
every day we were in the body,
which is why they expelled us,
because in every committee
I was on,
I stood up and spoke out
on the House floor
where some of the most outspoken members,
and they retaliated
not because of that one incidence of us
going to the well and joining
those young people protesting
gun violence,
but because they got tired
and did not feel like young black men
have a right to be at the same diocese.
Then they felt like young black men
don't have the right to sit
in the chamber with them.
They don't see us as equal.
The House speaker, Cameron
Sexton, has trafficked
in the rhetoric of racism.
He's traffic
in the rhetoric of racialized narratives.
And so we know what we're facing.
But it's worth
whatever sacrifice we have to make
because the future we want to live in
is what we're working for.
One last thing.
In an odd way, this has given you
a very big a much bigger platform.
The White House is weighing in
the current
and the former White House
current and former presidents
both weighing in on this.
How do you tend to use that
newly garnered platform,
elevated platform that you have
I mean, what
what our protest was about
when we went to the well to stand with
these young people was to
elevate their voices.
And so with this platform,
we hope to continue to lift up the issues
that that a week after mass shooting.
I represent a part
I represented a part of Nashville
and our community
still grieving communities and trauma.
These young people are begging us to say
we want to live in schools.
We must continue to lift up the issues.
And like I told my colleagues
who expelled me,
no matter
if they vote to expel me or not,
what I did was for their children
and grandchildren.
So we want their children
and grandchildren
to be safe from mass shootings.
We want them to live lives
where they can flourish and be children
and not have to do active
shooter drills or live in schools
that look like militarized zones.
And so we'll continue
to lift up the issue
and we'll continue
to speak truth to power.
And I'll be back at the Capitol
on Monday on the outside
with those protesting, demanding action
from my former colleagues.
Justin Jones,
we appreciate you joining us.
Our regards best to you
to the best of everything, to you
and your colleagues. Thank you so much.
Thank you.